[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 donde analizamos la
actualidad de la copa américa y la
eurocopa
a continuación nuestros titulares
italia de otra muestra de autoridad y
venció 2 a 1 a bélgica para acceder a
las semifinales de la eurocopa natura
fue superior y se citó con españa' que
venció por penales a suiza hoy se cierra
el cupo con los cuatro mejores
pero así supera un duro desafío y se
impuso 1 a 0 a chile para acceder a las
semifinales de la copa américa los de ti
te jugaron con 10 casi todo el segundo
tiempo por la expulsión de gabriel jesús
ahora chocarán con perú que eliminó por
penales a paraguay
colombia uruguay argentina ecuador
serrano cuartos de final de la copa
américa la tricolor y la celeste
disputan un duelo cerrado en brasilia
mientras que la albiceleste rinde otro
examen ante la dura actriz en goiánia
analizamos estos encuentros
como en cada jornada nos acompañan sara
castro directora del diario 'as'
colombia bienvenida a sala
y empezamos a palpitar las semis de
ambos torneos si empezamos con la
eurocopa que ya tiene una de sus
primeras semifinales confirmada tras las
victorias de italia y de españa en el
primer turno del viernes en la roja
debió esperar a los penales para vencer
a suiza tenis sacar ya en contra y
xherdan shaqiri marcaron en el tiempo
regular los helvéticos o se quedaron con
10 a 20 del final por la expulsión de
remo freud erin yann sommer fue figura
en la prórroga pero los de vladimir
pétkovic fallaron desde los 12 pasos
luego italia derrotó 2 a 1 a bélgica
nicolo varela y loren su insignia
anotaron para la azzurra romeros lukaku
de penal descontó para los 'diablos
rojos'
la nota negativa para los de roberto
mancini fue una lesión en el tendón de
aquiles de leonardo espinal sola quien
no estará para el resto del torneo esto
fue lo que dijo mancini tras el
encuentro dio peso y agregó mérito de
creo que merecimos anotar un gol más
probablemente no pide el penal pero me
dijeron que pues bastante dudoso
atlático esto
pero por esa razón era muy importante
jugar al máximo nivel y eso fue
exactamente lo que hicimos de venta de
no creo que hayamos podido hacerlo mejor
en este momento en potes imos fire saga
fue quizás el partido el mejor partido
el más completo de italia en lo que va
del torneo sobre todo por la calidad del
rival y quizás el peor de bélgica que
factores inclusiones para que se dirá si
está italia emociona ya lo habíamos
dicho en este espacio y emociona porque
porque sigue teniendo un juego valiente
es un juego profundo de mucha dinámica
incluso es un fútbol alegre cuando
defienden italia va a cada pelota con
convicción de bélgica que hay que decir
por supuesto fue un rival complicadísimo
y que da la sensación que esta
generación para empezar a desintegrarse
sin haber logrado un premio mayor no
sólo al talento sino al trabajo de
roberto martínez
preocupo porque no lograron
desequilibrar
aunque donnarumma fue fundamental en dos
ocasiones claras en el primer tiempo
pero aparece la figura por ejemplo de
ayer mido que un joven de 19 años
valiente talentoso y creo que eso habla
de lo que viene para el fútbol belga
también
más allá de lo colectivo que ya hemos
hablado de italia también es
impresionante ver los niveles
individuales cuando mira uno mira a
insigne a espina sola que
desafortunadamente se va a perder el
resto del torneo por genio es decir todo
el equipo tuvo un nivel altísimo
asumiendo los roles de roberto mancini y
esto habla de una reconstrucción con
base una idea no sólo táctica
interesante valiente de ir siempre a
buscar sino también que dejar la
creatividad del talento del jugador
italiano que durante muchos años ha sido
como subvalorado entonces veremos un
partido supremamente interesante en la
fase de semifinal sí porque enfrente
está está españa que un poco
desconcierta tienen alguna referencia
defensiva genera ocasiones pero no
siempre convierte pero aún así está
entre los cuatro mejores como analizamos
este españa españa sufrió pero clasificó
primero porque suiza es un gran equipo
trabajado tácticamente y tiene una
voluntad impresionante ya habían perdido
hay acá en la previa del partido
perdieron en bolos durante el partido y
luego cuando más lo necesitaron a
freiler por una expulsión y si bien el
equipo de luis enrique tuvo la pelota su
gran obsesión por un momento es un
equipo plano
pero en el fútbol también vale resistir
resistir desde la idea y lo mental y en
eso llega el equipo de luis enrique con
gran puntaje a esta semifinal y también
el fútbol es de noches épicas una noche
como la que vivió una y simón el portero
que sin duda es fundamental para esa
clasificación y ahora viajará a londres
españa va a tener que hacer su mejor
partido de esta copa si quiere ganarle a
italia una italia que sin duda va a
poner a prueba si esta idea que ya
sabemos está basada en esa posesión y
tiene oportunidades ante un equipo tan
dinámico como lo es el de mancini bien
del otro lado de la llave en estos
momentos se están disputando uno de los
partidos de semifinal en bakú está
ganándole dinamarca 2 a una república
checa y más tarde
inglaterra se mide ante ucrania en roma'
pasamos a su página y nos metemos de
lleno con la copa américa que tendrá a
brasil y perú como los animadores de una
de las semifinales en el primer turno
perú y paraguay empataron 3 a 3 en un
duelo cambiante la blanquirroja se
terminen poniendo por penales los de
berisso empezaron ganando por el gol de
gustavo gómez en gianluca la padula no
dio vuelta con un doblete y gómez dio la
roja
el primer tiempo júnior alonso igualó
yoshimar yotún puso el 3-2 peruano fue
expulsado andré carrillo y gabriel
ávalos consiguió la agónica igualdad
pero desde los 12 pasos prevalecieron
los de ricardo gareca luego brasil
superó 1 a 0 a un competitivo chile que
me lo dio la sorpresa lukas para que
está marcó el golazo de los de tite pero
de inmediato fue expulsado gabriel jesús
y la canarinha tuvo que aguantar la
ventaja ya la ponemos primero el foco en
este encuentro la generación dorada de
chile se despide de las copas américas
con un gran partido ante brasil que
demostró que también sabe sufrir qué
lindo es ver competir a chile lo
insistiré siempre luego me dirán que no
tuvo lo suficiente para hacerle daño a
brasil pero siempre aparecen los vidal
los arangues los pulgar y ahí para poner
en problemas a brasil y sobre todo para
demostrar eso no la jerarquía de una
generación que sin duda no pudo hacerle
daño a brasil porque también se enfrenta
a una calidad de jugadores impresionante
pero que es muy destacable y más en un
nuevo proceso como es el de lasarte por
parte de brasil creo que el punto más
alto es ver a neymar como líder en este
segundo tiempo no sólo es
desequilibrante ofensivamente sino que
además empieza a manejar los tiempos
el partido a hacer jugar a entender ese
rol que él tiene en la cancha más allá
de ser un buen jugador creo que a brasil
lo que le sigue faltando es que está muy
atado a esa concepción táctica de tite
que está preparando este equipo para
competir en el mundial y eso hace que
este talento este juego fluido y alegre
de brasil no se vea de tal manera de
todas formas bueno sigue como favorito
sigue como candidato tiene jugadores
impresionantes que en cualquier momento
definen un partido pero bueno ahí vimos
también que en esta copa américa hay
emoción y hay competitividad y sobre
todo esa tensión que es necesaria en
este tipo de fases y hablando de
emociones fue lo que le sobró a un perú
paraguay que no fue del todo bien jugado
pero tuvo goles cambiantes situaciones
cambiantes que nos deja este perú
paraguay sobre todo a perú de cara a lo
que viene habíamos anticipado un duelo
táctico que no fue tanto fue un partido
abierto de muchas emociones de errores
pero sobre todo eso la búsqueda del
partido y eso es súper valorable a
paraguay le expulsan a su capitán a
gustavo gómez idea y en lugar de meterse
empieza a buscar
una vez más a youtube como eje
fundamental de perú
carrillo que también lo expulsara iba a
ser una baja muy importante para el
equipo de ricardo gareca pero también
empezamos a ver el resultado de eso de
una consistencia en un proyecto en el
que se ha confiado en el técnico
argentino y que está siendo protagonista
en las últimas ediciones de copas
américas y en este tipo de torneo un
partido muy emocionante luego en los
penales paraguay tiene peor suerte que
lo que lo que hizo perú y bueno perú un
rival difícil para este brasil no lo
hemos visto tan convincente en todas las
fases del juego pero pero seguramente le
va a pelear al equipo de tite y los
cuartos de final se van a cerrar este
sábado con dos encuentros que también se
anticipan interesantes en el primer
turno en brasilia uruguay y colombia
protagoniza en un duelo cerrado con
aroma a revancha de aquella victoria
cafetera en el mundial de brasil-2014 en
la celeste regresa al visuales y los
cafeteros pierden amateurs uribe por
lesión y juan guillermo cuadrado
suspendido luego argentina con algunas
dudas y en la espera de la recuperación
de cristian romero enfrenta a ecuador
que repetiría el equipo que empató 1-1
con brasil antes de estos encuentros
hablaron oscar
en uruguay y leonel scaloni en argentina
nosotros
para el partido con colombia que será un
partido difícil es un rival que
respetamos mucho
vamos a tratar de seguir el camino que
hemos iniciado proponiendo la mejoría de
el juego
y conseguir los resultados que
necesitaban es un gran rival porque
tiene buenos jugadores porque viene con
la moral alta y porque además este
ha logrado buenos resultados en las
eliminatorias también
bajo esa condición no podemos más que
respetarlo y salir al campo con la total
humildad sabiendo de que es un partido
de fútbol muy difícil y que son 90
minutos que intentaremos pasar que es el
objetivo en el fútbol sudamericano hay
mucho respeto a los entrenadores hablan
bien de sus rivales y saben que en
ningún partido sencillo pero en el caso
de uruguay con las bajas que presenta
colombia tiene una obligación de
llevarse este encuentro creo que la
obligación es de demostrar que lo he
hecho en los últimos partidos esa
generación de juego ofensivo y no
pararse tan atrás es como una
responsabilidad con la que llegó a
uruguay este partido entendiendo que
reinaldo rueda no sólo tiene que suplir
las bajas que individualmente son
importantes sino también empezar a
mostrar esa idea sobre la que está
trabajando a futuro creo que colombia ha
sabido resolver situaciones pero aún no
se le nota una línea de trabajo muy
clara hacia dónde va el equipo el
partido interesantísimo yo creo que es
una palabra que repetimos en estos días
pero si es de mucho análisis para ver
cómo están estas elecciones una una
generación uruguaya que también empieza
a ser muy diferente que se sale del adn
adicional que tiene un mediocampo super
talentoso y pues los dos jugadores de
adelante que son un peligro para
cualquier defensa brevemente en pocas
líneas este argentina ecuador con la
obligación también siempre que queda el
lado argentino si ecuador con alfaro ha
mostrado cosas interesantes y es un
equipo que no baja los brazos tiene
problemas a la hora de las transiciones
defensivos pero seguramente va a
intentar buscar argentina esperemos que
ya haya superado ese momento complicado
en el que no sabe dominar los momentos
del partido con un mes y también muy
líder ojalá hoy vuelva a brillar porque
creo que ha sido también uno de los
puntos altos del torneo y creo que es un
duelo de técnicos argentinos un duelo de
equipos además que se conocen muy bien
bien en diario de copas repasamos otras
noticias vinculadas a estos torneos el
gobierno británico no prevé modificar el
plan de permitir más de 60.000
espectadores en wembley para las
semifinales y la final de la eurocopa
esto pese a las preocupaciones que han
expresado varios líderes europeos
incluyendo angela merkel por la
propagación de la variante del
coronavirus
richarlyson que está disputando la copa
américa con brasil fue incluido en la
lista para los juegos olímpicos el
delantero del everton está entre los 22
elegidos el seleccionador olímpico
pretendía sumar a vinicius pero real
madrid no accedió mientras disputa la
copa américa con argentina el futuro de
messi sigue sumando rumores según el
diario
aspar y san serván presentó una oferta
para incorporarlo barcelona espera
retenerlo
hasta aquí diario de copas muchas
gracias por acompañarnos muchas gracias
a todos ustedes sigan con más en france
24 y france 24 puntocom